well as the united states gets close to
the fourth of july holiday a number of
different shortages are threatening the
holiday i guess if you want to think
about it in the most standard way
uh but this is a good opportunity to
talk about a number of the different
areas in which there are shortages i
think it's important
for context why are we talking about
this we're talking about this because
number one i have no interest in hiding
shortages just because joe biden is
president that's a common one that i'm
accused of and secondly none of these
things have anything to do with joe
biden particularly when you consider the
global nature of many of these shortages
a few things to be aware of uh there is
a sriracha shortage this is uh i guess
i'm not wrong in calling it an asian
chili sauce i think that's the way it's
most typically described and there is a
a lot of breathless coverage of the
looming sriracha shortage i love
sriracha but for me
first of all by the way if you really
it's just the primary sriracha that
there's a shortage of so there are all
sorts of other
uh sriracha brands as well you can also
look at other hot sauces but indeed
there is the expectation that the
country's most popular brand of sriracha
will be in a shortage coming soon
uh fo
yuufong foods the california-based
producer of this sauce
says they will have to scale back
production due to an abysmal spring crop
of mexican red jalapenos
nothing to do with joe biden joe it is
not joe biden's fault that in mexico
they've had a bad crop of red jalapenos
okay
with fourth of july coming up mustard a
global mustard shortage is looming
ahead of summer barbecues as reported by
axios
um
yeah a few of the largest mustard brands
like kraft heinz
say they don't expect shortages but
there are some mustards which will be
um experiencing stock issues
i love a good mustard i'm partial to
grain mustard and brown deli mustard i'm
just not big on the yellow stuff it sort
of seems a little bit cartoonish to me
and i know baseball fans won't react
kindly to that no but in all seriousness
i love mustard
there will be mustards available
maybe just not the one that you like
more seriously
there is a medical contrast dye shortage
and medical contrast dyes are used for a
number of different imaging procedures
and surgical procedures uh i talked
recently
of my girlfriend's um perforation that
she had and one of the ways that they
confirm the perforation has been fixed
is they use one of these contrast dyes
under imaging and then see if any of the
dye escapes where it's supposed to be
these are
very important medical
materials
it's used in diagnosing and treating
stroke aneurysm cardiac conditions these
are essential to hospitals in many ways
there is a
delay happening there
the global chip shortage will continue
this predates joe biden
and has nothing to do with joe biden and
industry experts don't believe there
will be relief on the chip shortage
until 2023
there is a nurse shortage anecdotally
shreveport louisiana warning of a nurse
shortage but this is happening um
nationally in in many different places
uh when we've recently been in the
hospital uh for the birth and for
everything else that's been going on
many traveling nurses who just like
they'll they'll literally come up from
like baltimore to new york city for a
week
and just work a week in a hospital
unfamiliar to them then go back down to
baltimore a lot of that going on to try
to deal with the shortage in some areas
that is expected to continue
and then lastly for me there's other
shortages as well but lastly for what
i'll talk about today a pilot shortage
could lead to flight delays and
cancellations and we have already seen
that already seen that so this is a
major a large issue
which we will continue to follow
hopefully everybody's fourth of july
will be okay
republican congressman adam kinzinger is
lashing out at republican congresswoman
lauren bobert remember that lauren
bobert recently said i'm sick and tired
of this separation of church and state
it's kind of the constitution lauren but
you're tired of it adam kinzinger
calling it the christian taliban as a
reminder here is the clip from a couple
of days ago
lauren beaubert going full
theocracy saying
church and state i'm sick of it the
reason we had so many over
reaching regulations in our nation is
because the church complied right
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
[Music]
whoa
well it turns out that that is crazy and
fellow republican launching a civil war
salvo from within the republican party
adam kinzinger says quote there is no
difference between this
this meaning you know this video of
lauren bauber that we just watched
there's no difference between this
and the taliban we must oppose
the christian taliban
i say this as a christian
has a republican politician
straight up said christian taliban
before because they love to talk about
sharia law
and oh it's bad and it's gonna it's
coming and
hold on a second
the christian version of sharia law it
was what has actually been plaguing this
country for a very long time i disagree
with adam kinzinger politically but i
have some respect for him now i know
it's easier to put country over party
the way that he's doing when you're
leaving i understand that i'm not naive
i get it he's in a position where he
doesn't care because he's leaving
but it is amazing how the bar has been
lowered democrats today
would be thrilled to some degree to deal
with the republicans from 15 years ago
not that those were good people we
shouldn't see them as good people
but 15 years ago
the republicans were much more
reasonable to deal with that being said
the republicans of 15 years ago
are responsible
for
the republican party today being what it
is and what i mean by that is
they didn't condemn
the start
of the rhetoric that led to trumpism
today they didn't condemn the extremism
they didn't say well we've got to stop
this here or here or here they allowed
it to keep going
so while i would much rather be dealing
with the republicans of 15 years ago
than people like lauren bobert that's
for sure
we also have to understand the
historical context which i talked about
with many people including noam chomsky
on the show before
that they are also responsible for what
we are seeing today but to the extent
that adam kinzinger is willing to call
it out to the extent that adam kinzinger
is maybe going to change some
republicans mind and get some republican
to go hey you know what
the bobert
version of republicanism is crazy
it's not even constitutional tired of
separation of church and state it's like
being tired of the first amendment
lauren which i thought you cared about
um to the extent that he might have an
impact on anybody i gladly welcome adam
kinzinger's comments
if you want an example
of how low
the anti-choice right is willing to go
the mississippi republican speaker of
the house
says that even if a twelve-year-old is
raped by her dad and is pregnant as a
result
she must be forced to carry the baby to
term
it's
unconscionable
it's unconscionable we have an article
it's pretty pretty vile
12 year old incest victims should birth
dad's child
house speaker gunn says this article is
by our friend ashton pittman who's been
a guest on the show
mississippi house speaker phillip gunn
says abortion should be illegal
even for a 12-year-old rape victim
carrying her father or uncle's child
he made the remarks to reporters in the
house
in the hours sorry after the u.s supreme
court struck down roe v wade and dobbs v
jackson women's health organization
uh i have video i know that this is
really really really tough to watch
take a listen
i believe life begins at conception
and every life is valuable
and and that's those are those are my
personal beliefs
that is that is my personal belief i
believe life begins at conception now
life begins at conception is sort of a
cop-out
i don't know anyone who would deny
that there is a form of life at
conception
the relevant question is
when are we talking about a person and
in just about no other way are people
like this guy
willing to provide the other personhood
benefits to
uh you know a
a two-day old
uh clump of cells that he would call
life um they don't want to uh provide
child support they don't think it's the
basis for citizenship they you know
we've gone through it before
but
that position
a 12 year old should be forced to carry
the incestuous pregnancy to term it's
sick to even say it
it's not pro-child and it's not
pro-woman and then i realize wait a
second there is no woman it's another
child another 12-year-old child but
we're supposed to believe that this is
pro-life
and that he has the interests of
the child in mind
uh our friend ashton pittman has been
reporting on this and he writes quote in
mississippi poor mothers only have
access to postpartum medicaid coverage
for two months after giving birth this
year the republican-led mississippi
senate voted overwhelmingly to vote to
extend that to two months
speaker gunn
killed the bill
also adding later in a twitter thread
quote mississippi boasts the nation's
highest infant mortality rate highest
fetal mortality rate lowest overall life
expectancy rate and highest coveted 19
death rate mississippi's maternal
mortality rate is 1.9 times higher than
the nation as a whole mississippi is a
mess
it's not an insult to the people it's
just the facts folks health care in
mississippi is a disaster education in
mississippi is a disaster the economy of
mississippi is it's a disaster
and i feel bad about it for the people
who live there
and what they want to do
is say force 12-year-olds
impregnated by their fathers
to carry the pregnancy to term
what they want should be criminal
truly horrible people
let me know your thoughts is this even a
shock to you find me on twitter at
deepakman the david pakman show is an
audience supported program we have a
membership program it is completely cool
and completely legal oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad yeah and you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting 22 to get a discount
let's start calls via discord we take
phone calls at davidpakman.com
discord they're not really phones but
you know we still call them phone calls
let's start today with our friendly
neighbors to the north going to
yol from ontario
is this ontario canada joelle
oh boy
yoel if you unmute i'll be able to hear
you
yol from ontario last chance
an inauspicious start today that is
disappointing let's go to mark from los
angeles mark i'm confident you'll save
us hello hello you're you're on the air
yes
awesome fantastic
i love your show um
uh first of all i just wanna i mean
people have already already said this
but have you seen more signs that
um
that the abortion issue is actually
going to might shift the needle in terms
of um the midterms yes um yes i have
because i
yeah because i the funny thing is i was
i'd work with a lot of folks to like you
know
blue call a lot of conservatives
and one of the things
uh
that they don't seem to realize is i
actually know
a woman who is a born-again christian
she's a relative of mine who is
fervently
uh
pro-abortion uh she actually had one
and she is unapologetic it's kind of
shocking when you talk to her so you
don't realize how many people
are actually in favor of their rights
you know to be able to do what they want
to do with their bodies
that's that's one thing i just wanted to
say is uh
you know i think this might be a big uh
touchstone a shockwave that might might
overtake uh the next election because
it's just it's just something it's one
thing when it's ambiguous but when
someone when they take something away
from you you realize you wake up
you know yeah so two things on that
number one
more
of the country is in favor of abortion
being legal in most cases than at any
time during the roe v wade era so and
that's exactly why as mark points out
there's even born again christians or
whatever uh who are in favor of
individuals having that right and
secondly
every
generic ballot poll that i have seen
this week
shows democrats now leading where three
months ago democrats were losing so i do
think mark that democrats have a shot
thanks to what's going on with roe v
wade and thanks to what's going on with
the lack of gun safety regulation
well that's fantastic oh and also i
wanted to say congratulations
the funny thing is i i dip out i do i
actually take your advice i dip out of
politics sometimes because it becomes so
toxic that i just can't take it anymore
and i and i stopped listening to you all
i'm i'm a subscriber by the way thank
you but i just stopped listening i take
a break for like a week or something and
i came back and all of a sudden you had
a baby
you were gone listen i was shocked i all
of a sudden came back and i had a baby
if you think you were shocked to hear it
i was shocked to be doing it you know
mark
wait is is this one of those like um she
didn't know he was pregnant no
tv
it is not it is nothing like that it's
just still that shocking
oh okay okay well yeah i i remember
watching a gynecologist say that one of
the most amazing things about her job
that she never gets over is the fact
that she walks in the room and then by
the time they're finished there's an
extra person in the world yeah well try
going to the hospital with two people
and coming out with three it's quite a
shocker
well i want to congratulation dave oh
and one last thing i want to say is you
know i work as a stagehand okay and one
of the things that i never could get
is remember the whole um voting rights
bills that you know that failed
yes you know
well
i worked on um
the super bowl and like the the the
person who sung the star spangled banner
is black i'm afraid american is black
the the person who sung the national
anthem is black the overwhelming
majority of the football members are
black and i'm just like standing here
like like working i'm just like why
can't we we need to like just like do a
protest do like what's that famous greek
play where all the women wouldn't have
sex with the men until you know they
stop the war we need to just like
protest or something or get active in
order to try to force these people
because that is a five billion dollar
event
wow
black folks said you know what well yes
yes i was shocked too it was a 5 billion
at so far stadium that that thing in
terms of like all the money that's made
off of off of the super bowl it's 5
billion dollars i got you mark it's
quite a number listen mark you've said
it all i'm gonna let you go i look
forward to hearing from you again okay
okay thanks a lot how are you
shot out of a cannon today on fire
completely on fire
okay
let's go next to john from kentucky
welcome john
hi there
oh boy
dear god
john you're coming through all modulated
like you're a robot you're not a robot
are you
i am not can you hear me now yeah that's
better you sounded like c-3po three cpo
or whatever it is
yeah as a star wars fan i can say you
were right the first time okay uh or a
previous star wars fan but that's not
what i'm calling about okay um so i was
keeping track of the supreme court stuff
over the last couple of weeks just like
everybody else has um and of course the
dobbs decision was heartbreaking to see
what happened to
you know actively creating half of our
population as second-class citizens
that's you know something that we all
have to contend with over the next but
what the decision that really really
caught my attention over the last couple
of days was the kennedy decision
and while i used to be a christian and i
can understand why christians initially
believe that you know it's an oculus
it's a football coach he believes his
creator is going to protect him and so
he should pray over people i can
understand the christian perspective yep
but what is important to me
[Music]
the decision itself but the fact that's
of the case in his decision
like by saying that the uh by saying
that the uh the coach was almost uh by
saying the coach was just quietly
praying to himself in midfield at any
time that any other person he wasn't
acting as a representative right but
then justice sotomayor posted a picture
of him praying with the entire team very
clearly acting as a representative and
the football coach at that time yeah
like i have a conservative aunt who
argues as this um facts versus
alternative fact stuff it's just a
little bit scary seeing that type of
argumentation coming from the supreme
court now without a doubt you're
absolutely right it was not a quiet
prayer it was a huge thing the coach
with multiple circles of players around
him and then media around them uh it's
implicitly coercive because of the power
dynamics and uh john you're completely
right in your assessment
absolutely absolutely um and just like
mark i just want to say congratulations
on the baby man and uh yeah you have a
wonderful rest of the day all right
there we go there's john from kentucky
let's go next to john from sacramento
john welcome
john from sacramento you're on the air
and last chance for john from sacramento
you're not muted so i'm guessing you
have the wrong microphone selected in
discord uh one last shot at
fixing that
all right john from sacramento not
working let's go to chris from philly
chris i know you're going to save us
with a properly configured microphone
right my
friend hopefully
all right that's not bad
so i've been waiting to do this for a
long time
chris from philly black
uh
chris are you saying you're you're
identifying yourself as a black man is
that what you're saying
oh yes sir okay
well thank you
one
one thing uh i i have a pet peeve with
republicans right now yeah as with the
whole world we think
and
no one's really sitting there saying
nothing about syria law anymore
oh right in other words let me see if i
understand your point you're saying they
used to talk about oh they want to take
over american law with sharia law
but now that they're trying to
succeeding to some degree at taking over
american civil law with christianity
now they don't care about that anymore
factual absolutely well listen adam
kinzinger i talked about this on the
show adam kinzinger is calling uh i
don't know if you saw lauren beaubert
recently said she's tired of separation
of church and state and adam kinzinger
who's a republican called it uh
christian taliban which is exactly what
it is
at the end of the day like
i guess you can say she's saved again
after now i mean she got exposed right
right
yeah no it's great these people are
hypocrites and they're dangerous but the
really scary thing chris is
if they do well in november
all bets are off as to how far they can
go with this they they could really do
some serious damage to the country
yeah without a doubt
yeah
all right my friend anything else
no that was it all right chris from
philly thanks for the call
no problem all right chris from philly
concise what a beautiful phone call love
it
let's go to mike from southeastern
pennsylvania mike welcome
mike from southeastern pennsylvania
you're on the air
and last chance for mike from
southeastern pennsylvania by the way i
know people start to think the tech
problems are on my end
they're not i can see what's going on
like this is a user who has um
this is a user who's gone actually okay
that's why i can't hear them they just
hung up let's go next to dave from
windsor dave from windsor welcome
oh hi mr pacman welcome
hi i
didn't really have a question to
sometimes like listen to this stuff when
i'm doing work
congrats on the kid
all right dave from windsor thank you i
will put you back in the queue so you
could listen what boy what a fog some
must be a full moon right not that i
believe in that type of thing let's go
to trenton from detroit trenton welcome
give us a question sir
oh hey david um
so my question is i guess considering
everything's going on with the january 6
committee obviously damning testimony
and yeah i mean even yesterday which is
the testimony is probably some of the
most damning since watergate
do you think realistically it's going to
actually change anybody's mind about
your 2022 primaries or the uh 2024
presidential election because
unfortunately i don't think it will i
think it'll change some nominal number
of minds i don't think it'll be a game
changer however if it leads to charges
which i don't think it will but if it
led to serious criminal charges against
people i think it might but just if it's
just they do the committee and then it's
over
and then we have the november election
and then that's it um i think it will
not do anything significant no i think
you're right
you know from from my end i have a lot
of people that are kind of in that trump
mega land who i guess i work with and
with a lot of the other stuff they talk
about it and deny it with this it seems
like they're not even tuned in so
i'm not sure if it's a good sign for
sanity or not it's not a particularly
good sign i mean that this is always a
thing the people who most should be
watching these hearings are just not
watching the hearings that's it's a sad
reality
yeah
well
all right but listen we've gotta vote at
least you're you'll vote right
oh of course
everyone must vote all right trenton
thank you for the call
all right trenton very very good
let's go next to blake from seattle
blake welcome
blake from seattle you were on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
um yeah hey um i was just uh
wondering i kind of wanted to run
something by you
um when it comes to
taxing the rich okay i uh wanted to know
if it would be a good idea to tax like
the rich on
the
loans that they get
um
sorry i'm kind of nervous no you do fine
so let me see if i understand the
question
you're saying like let me let me explain
it and we'll see if i'm on the right
track here blake okay
okay
so a mechanism that sometimes the
wealthy use
is they have all of these stocks and
bonds
if they sell the stocks and bonds and
there's been appreciation they owe
capital gains so what you can do is get
like a pledged asset loan or otherwise
take a loan against those stocks and
bonds so you say hey i've got 10 million
in stock
give me a 5 million loan i'll give you
the stock as collateral
the 5 million loan doesn't count as
income and then you just spend the 5
million and you're sort of avoiding the
taxes at least while you're alive that's
kind of what you're suggesting right
yeah so i was saying like i'm saying
like maybe there's like a threshold so
like a normal person can get like a
normal loan without getting taxed for it
right um but like the super rich would
have to pay
um taxes on it and then i don't care if
like in the end they want to you know
write it off on their taxes as like the
5 million that they borrowed even if the
stock appreciates and they have to pay
the rest of the capital gains when they
sell it but i feel like that would
prevent more of the
rich super rich people from like
avoiding taxes yep i mean listen you're
thinking along the the same lines that
we recently did an interview with an
inequality economist who said
similar similar idea is
let's tax the rich when their money is
just sitting in order to you know kind
of
influence them to put the money
uh into the economy in some kind of more
stimulative way
i think these are all totally reasonable
ideas and blake i think it's great that
you're thinking about it the changes
that would be rook it's just like i
never say never
but the degree of changes to the way the
tax code works in order to do that
that's far more complicated than like
changing the top tax rate or the uh
capital gains rate so i don't want to
say it'll never happen but it'll
probably never happen because that's
just not the way loan proceeds work
yeah it's unfortunate because i feel
like that would uh solve a lot of the a
lot of the problems and uh it would
prevent that whole wealth tax thing from
people who feel like that's unfair yep
absolutely no you're thinking along the
right lines there's just there's
economic realities and there's political
realities
yeah all right well thanks david i
appreciate it all right blake from
seattle very good call
we're going to take a very short break
if you're hanging on to talk to me just
keep holding because i'm going right
back to the phones in a moment
okay let's hear from more of the most
important people
the audience without the audience i'm a
guy in a room with a microphone and it's
really really sad
let's go next to dave from brooklyn dave
welcome
dave from brooklyn you're on the air
you are muted you've got to unmute
yourself
in order to talk to me
and last call for dave from brooklyn who
has muted himself
and dave has quit all right let's go to
an old friend issa from london isa
welcome
hey uh david
um following on from what i think it was
john he was talking about the uh the
kennedy praying case yes
so i'm i'm an nfl fan myself um
unfortunately i'm a cardinals fan so the
seasons are spent in misery for the most
part fair but i was thinking it's a bit
strange how it's the only sports league
in the whole world and i guess the only
sport in the whole world where
uh religion
uh specifically christianity seems to be
i guess ingrained in the culture
do you what do you think about that
because uh you're saying christianity is
ingrained in the nfl how is that
uh
maybe not uh not in the nfl but even in
college football and even in the the
high school level of the sport like
i've heard about
the majority of the players
uh
being christian and i've heard
uh instances of daily practice and
training sessions
where guys have prayer circles and it
goes back to that thing where you're
expected to bow your head and sort of
just join in out of respect yeah and if
you don't then that affects your social
standing
within the squad and with the coach
agree totally i mean a lot of the top
high school programs and college
programs are in some of the most
religious parts of the country and that
i absolutely agree with
yeah yeah like alabama and clemson for
example yep um but then like you know
guys like tim tebow um who obviously
blocked um but then he went on fox and
he was talking about uh his religious
beliefs you know i heard stories about
guys like him for example
when he was at the combine before he
joined the league
he
there was some instance where he uh said
to everyone hey guys let's have a prayer
circle and apparently he was laughed at
um
but uh yeah i i think it's just a bit
strange
uh how how much uh religion seems to be
ingrained in the
the culture on and off the field
i agree with you i mean it doesn't
resonate with me but it's uh
you know it it is what it is i think it
is true that it is less present in other
major sports um i mean you don't hear
about the big christian presence in like
soccer for example you know soccer is
much smaller in the united states also
but uh i agree with you completely to me
it's all a bit weird
yeah same it's also just like at the end
of the day
is it
that if both teams pray and one team
wins did god choose that team was it
because they practiced more or because
they prayed more i mean it's always all
a little bit strange to me for that
reason as well
yeah exactly yeah all right things are
otherwise good in london
not really no but
oh what's going on
well i mean you know if we if we were
by the time the show is
like the the latest uh affairs will
probably be our day you know there's
like something new each week um
what's the most recent thing probably um
the the uk tour is looking to repeal uh
a european based human rights act
because they wanted to
deport asylum seeking immigrants to
orlando yeah um
i don't know if you heard about that no
i did not i haven't been following them
yeah so there was a plane
there was a plane ready to
deport them
and then right at the last second the
european-based human rights council
blocked it
so now they want to they want to repeal
these
these human rights laws so that they can
proceed with uh
basically deporting immigrants
wow so not that different than what
republicans want to do here it sounds
like not really no
hey issa before i let you go can you
name three countries that start with the
letter g
g
yeah uh
gabon
gambia germany beautiful all right thank
you my friend good to talk to you
see you all right there you go there's
issa from london giving us a little
trivia as well
um let's see who else we have holding on
today oh let's go to taylor from indiana
taylor you've called in before right
uh i don't believe that i have no okay
all right well welcome anyway
thank you what's on your mind i wanted
to
well i wanted to read a quote from john
adams and then discuss it
okay i'm a little hesitant do you have a
question
i do okay
um he said this uh pertaining to
the forming of the country the american
revolution and their uh constitution
okay he said quote
it will never be pretended that any
persons employed in that service
had interviews with the gods
or
were in any degree under the inspiration
of heaven
more than those that work upon ships or
houses or laboring and merchandise or
agriculture okay it will forever be
acknowledged that these governments were
contrived merely by the use of reason
and the senses
end quote
i'm wondering i guess my question is
how did we get to this point that it
seems like right
like somebody cannot be even elected to
office without invoking some type of
religion i know
and what do we do about it if there's
anything we can
what we do about it is we need a less
christian nationalist supreme court so
that the decisions increasingly separate
church and state rather than blend them
together but the big picture i mean the
point you're getting to is
you have all these right wing christian
dominionist nationalist types
who want to ignore everything the
founding fathers said
and instead go hey
they were personally religious therefore
they probably didn't want separation of
church and state ignoring everything
they said which is absolutely nuts
right and that's it's for the most part
a myth that they were
that the majority of the founders were
very religious yeah what i mean tell me
what you know about that i i know that
many of them were religious but not all
well so
one example i know of
thomas jefferson
is famous for editing the bible with a
razor blade cutting out all the
supernatural parts
um there i'm not here to like promote
a book necessarily but there's a good
book um
by andrew seidl constitutional attorney
yep we've interviewed him um
that i've been listening to that book
um
and there's all kinds of good
information in there the book's called
the founding myth
why christian nationalism is un-american
indeed
and there's just there's so many lies
from like
all of the
all of the supposed
super
christian things that george washington
did
like praying in the snow at valley forge
and things like that it's all just
completely made up
well i don't know enough about that to
say for sure i'll research it but your
main point is absolutely well taken and
i appreciate you making it
thank you very much all right taylor
very nice phone call appreciate it let's
uh let's talk to some other people i
mean listen but why not right we're
doing it
let's go to emmanuel from new york
emmanuel welcome welcome back i know
i've spoken to you right
yeah you have it all right beautiful
uh i i have a question for you like um
what do you want
what do you think like um do you think
do you think political violence would be
necessary
because like if you look at history
people have used political violence like
do you know about the country rhodesia
you know you heard about it right i know
i'm familiar with rhodesia yeah yeah
basically like they were treated the
majority of black people like crap yeah
and so they fought back and you know
they won the war because zimbabwe is out
and now thing so like um do you think
that we can apply that to like what's
happening in the supreme court was a
voting issue with the voting issue
abortion and the policing in america
you know uh maybe this is me being
naively optimistic but i also from a
practical standpoint don't think that
violence is going to be the solution
here because violence is not going to
let me see how i can put this the united
states right now it's almost like a
logistical problem violence to achieve
goals in the united states the us is
mostly
blue you know left-leaning cities
within
kind of like purple
metro areas
inside of right-leaning rural areas
across a vast expanse of land
and i just don't know from a practical
standpoint how even just saying like if
we're okay
morally with using violence to achieve
change i don't know how in a country
like the us that's how you do it it just
seems like chaos and and uh
death and injury and insanity
without actually really achieving
political change to say we're we're just
going to use violence i'm also morally
opposed to it but that's a different
question
like in zimbabwe they did achieve the
girls because you know you know what
happened to it i'm not that familiar
with zimbabwe in history
oh okay
okay like okay so like one more question
do you think the the uh the what
happened supreme with abortion will
change the effects of the latino vote
because like my my parents vote for
democrat but like if you look at them
they're very conservative actually but
like because i saw this television
you know that spanish channel yeah
and basically one woman said let's see
what you said um i'm not i'm democrat i
i don't like abortion so like what do
that i like in my mind like wait so can
this actually change like latino latino
vote so it is true so the latino vote in
the u.s is interesting the latino vote
is generally left-wing other than cubans
and some venezuelans but the latino vote
is also very catholic and so there is
more anti-abortion sentiment among the
latino vote than some might believe
i think if there is any
impact from the roe v wade decision on
2022 i think it helps democrats i don't
know how to slice it and dice it within
the latino vote but i think the polling
is already telling us that if anybody's
going to benefit from the roe v wade
decision it's going to be democrats in
the fall we'll see
so but do you think uh
do you think there have a little effect
or no
i think that on in general or on the
latino vote
in general yes i think that the roe v
wade decision will have an effect and it
will help democrats in the fall
all right thank you for the question and
good luck with the baby all right thank
you very much appreciate the call
that does it for today folks i know i
didn't get to everyone i never do i'm
sorry i'm sorry but we got to a bunch of
people
and we will speak to more people next
week we'll take a quick break and be
right back all right it is time for the
friday mailbag and what a mailbag it is
if you have something to say you can
email info davidpakman.com respectful
messages are always preferred but they
can be about absolutely anything that's
on your mind so let's start today with
vincent vincent
is uh as usual not happy with me and
he's not happy with jews and okay so
vincent says why would any jew or black
be in favor of gun control
if i were a member of a group that was
put in danger of extermination as the
jews were by 30s and 40s germany i would
never give up my arms similarly the very
first jim crow laws passed after
reconstruction were laws prohibiting the
ownership of firearms by blacks if
someone ever enslaved me i would never
turn over my guns an armed person is a
citizen an unarmed person is a potential
slave so this is uh this this particular
email is not overtly anti-semitic this
vincent guy
every email is about jews one way or the
other he can't send an email without
mentioning jews but to the point here
first of all
there's two sides to this number one
um the whole concept of if the jews had
guns in germany there would have been no
holocaust it has been studied
extensively by historians and it has
been widely debunked it is not true that
if jews had handguns in in germany um or
even rifles in germany right before the
holocaust
that it would have prevented it and
similarly in the united states when
folks think handguns and ar-15s are
going to prevent government tyranny if
it really came to it with the tanks and
the blackhawk helicopters and the
shoulder-mounted rpgs
it's not so either the argument doesn't
make sense or you're saying citizens
should be able to own those arms or you
know i've actually talked to ben shapiro
about this
and you can find that conversation on
our youtube channel
but the second piece is the following
one
i am sensitive to the idea
that government tyranny aside
is it really good if only the right-wing
nuts have the guns and that's why
many of my liberal friends are now
firearms owners and as i've said before
i don't talk about my own
ownership or lack thereof of firearms
but there are many people i know who say
i don't even really like guns but i
don't want only the right wing nuts to
have them and it's so it is it is sort
of a race to the bottom that's the sad
thing about it
next email is from nathan nathan writes
in about the overton window and says
david sir are you familiar with the
overton window this concept
seems to be the reason why pence has
been characterized as saving democracy
by simply doing his job opposed to
trump's insanity it's similar to the
concept i've heard you describe before
as hypernormalization adam curtis rocks
2. this concept is very hard to work
into conversations with the trump
supporters in my life any tips to deal
much love from a very red upstate new
york area yeah i've been i've been
spending more and more time in upstate
new york it is shockingly right wing and
you know when you look at new york as a
state it's very blue but that it's
extremely skewed by the city and a few
other a few other spots but i've spent a
lot of time lately like in the hudson
area and right in in hudson um it's
quite blue but everywhere around
i haven't looked at the maps but it
looks very deep red you know joe biden
has dementia uh
lawn signs and all sorts of different
stuff but yes
um it is absolutely true
that
when the republican party has lost its
mind
when mike pence says
i can't overturn the results some people
go what a hero what what a pro-democracy
hero he is when liz cheney says
hey um
joe biden really won
and trump incited the january 6th friday
we go wow what a heroic reasonable
republican because in comparison
they seem that way but these are not
heroes these are just some of the few
somewhat attached to reality voices that
remain in the republican party
neil wrote in about my alex jones
impression and neil says david since you
asked
i don't really like your alex jones
impression not because it isn't very
good but because as a person with a lisp
i cringe heavily when people fake lisp
to me it seems your impression is just a
heavy lisp not a heavy smoker as the
caller mentioned
anyway love the show yeah
is that even a lisp like when when alex
jones says
globalish
i don't think of that as a lisp i think
of a lisp as something else
where anyway i'm not i'm not going to
even mimic it now we're not making fun
of lisps
we're not doing any of it we're not
doing any of it um that being said there
is this thing i don't know if it's a
list but i don't know if you guys have
noticed that
don jr and ivanka
they seem to have fake teeth that are a
little bit too big for them
and
it makes them speak in a weird way i
don't think that's a lisp either maybe i
just don't know enough about what counts
as a lisp
but
anyway we're certainly not making fun of
lisps here on the show thank you neil
jillian wrote in about fuel prices
jillian says fuel prices have an impact
on cost of living that's undeniable but
it amazes me that americans cannot see
the whole picture for a long time now
the low cost of fuel in the u.s has been
an enviable luxury as seen from other
countries now prices have risen across
the world in fact in ghana where i
currently live the price of a gallon of
diesel has rocketed to 717 or 595 a
gallon depending on whether you use uk
or usa gallons this is in a country
where many live well below the poverty
line and this price rise has extreme
effects i sympathize with all people who
are suffering at the moment not just
those in one country yeah so we one of
the things we have to acknowledge is it
can both be true that paying 450 a
gallon instead of 250 a gallon in the
united states is a major impact on a lot
of families that's true
and also prices in the us for fuel are
really low compared to the rest of the
world for the most part other than some
extremely you know oil producing rich
nations i think like in the emirates or
gap fuel is really cheap
um
but that's because fuel prices in the us
have not been accurate in terms of
representing the true cost of fuel fuel
gasoline prices are subsidized in the
u.s
and the production is subsidized so what
that means is uh there's a lot of
environmental i'm sorry
the production is subsidized and the
environmental impact is not accurately
reflected by the prices that we pay
so we are not accurately charging the
end user for gasoline and diesel that's
that's the truth in the united states
and when when gas prices more accurately
reflect their full cost including on the
environment people drive much smaller
fuel-efficient vehicles when i was in
spain
about uh
somewhere between a month and ten years
ago i don't know it's a blur no i think
last summer when i was in spain last
summer yeah ten nine ten months ago
i rented um a relatively fuel efficient
vehicle i don't even remember what it
was there's all these little vehicles
that they have in europe that we don't
have here in the u.s stick shift little
hatchback
and quite fuel efficient and it was
still really expensive to drive around
because i don't you know you have to
convert euro to a dollar and you have to
convert liters to gallons and do a whole
thing
i think it was roughly seven something a
gallon
and uh just doing a reasonable amount of
driving still cost a bunch the tolls are
very high
driving around is much more accurately
priced in europe and in other parts of
the world so 100
jillian is correct
gerson wrote in
about david beardman and says hello
david i am writing this to implore you
to grow out your beard i see limitless
potential in your facial hair clean up
the
neckline set your follicles free i
assure you you will have elegant
whiskers in no time use jojoba oil
and a beard balm of your choice to keep
everything healthy and moisturized a
boar hair brush is also a worthwhile
investment sincerely a man with a
similar beard yeah i you know what
happened was when the baby came and then
i had the you know the unexpected time
off and all these different things i
just didn't have time to shave
um last night i did i did a little
cleanup and i cleaned up the neckline
and everything i am willing to get
creative with the beard
uh that is that is not something i am
afraid of let's see where it goes
um fletch wrote in and says why not arm
the military with baseball bats and
knives sir a common argument i'm coming
across from the right is that knives and
baseball bats can kill yet we have no
restrictions on those so why have
restrictions on guns in that case why
not send the troops into battle only
with knives and baseball bats surely if
a bat is just as lethal as a
high-powered rifle then purchasing said
rifles for the troops is a waste of
taxpayer dollars of course yeah i mean
it's it's sort of tongue-in-cheek but
there's some sense to that
if it were true
that knives and baseball bats and
hammers and all these things are
potentially just as deadly as guns
then why waste all the money on guns for
the military and for police yes now
there are some pretty easy holes to poke
in that
but um
it is a fair question to be asking
regardless
philip writes in
and says what's the controversy over the
word expat david the following question
is in regards to a response of yours
about how to identify ukraine on the
youtube video entitled trump on his
knees for jesus that's a great video as
an expat living in thailand i did not
know there was a controversy surrounding
the term expat
could you explain it again so here's the
deal with the term expat i have two
answers to this on the one hand the
reason the term expat has gotten
controversial
is that there's a sort of like
racialized class element to it and i'll
explain it to you
when someone from thailand comes to the
united states
we rarely call them expats we call them
immigrants
and when an american goes to thailand
we often don't say i'm an immigrant
people say i'm an expat so i think you
can understand how implicit in that
there's potentially a class and a race
element to it but but i also want to go
further
um
sometimes
when
the white dude you know assuming philip
is an american white dude
when the white dude goes to thailand
they're not going and finding work in
the local economy they're either going
already as
sort of semi-retired or they're going
and working a remote american job and
earning u.s dollars while in thailand
that's different than someone from
thailand who comes to the united states
and and has to find work let's call it
like non-um professional
like not a doctor that comes to the u.s
to become a doctor from time but people
in the service industry and so on the
one hand there's this kind of race class
thing where when the americans go
elsewhere we call them expats and when
people from other countries come to the
us we call them immigrants sometimes
there is a difference which is you go
and you're you know a
remote worker for a tech company in
thailand and that's a little bit
different because your relationship to
the thai economy is then something other
than when someone comes to the us and
works like in the service industry so i
think that there are differences between
types of immigration
and that's the controversy that exists
over the term expat here's a few bonuses
jesse commented on youtube dear david
parkman you have never needed a gun and
you have no right to speak about guns
well number one saying i have no right
to speak that doesn't sound like you
support free speech i have no right to
speak but this is very dumb this is like
saying if you've not been in the
military you can't have an opinion about
the iraq war
we heard some right wingers saying that
during george w bush's iraq war that's
silly and also you have never needed a
gun i have chosen
not to talk about my personal
relationship to guns on the show
including my
ownership or lack of ownership of
firearms so i think it's neither here
nor there but you don't know anything
about my relationship to guns okay jesse
thank you very much
another youtube comment
no cap but i honestly thought pacman was
like 26 or 27 years old tops please
share your skincare routine david okay
here's my skincare routine
i use face lotion with spf 15.
i i just use it okay so when i'm out
there
i've got sunscreen summer
winter spring fall
i've got spf
and then otherwise that's really it i
use a vitamin c cleanser in the shower
thank you very much
and lastly from john john says
people wake up
mr packman is our enemy mr packman hates
the common american i wonder why he
didn't talk about biden's mental health
i've actually talked about it many times
also why did he not talk about biden
stopping the feds from dealing with the
virus and making it the state's problem
uh what
funny wasn't that biden's big campaign
promise to end the virus what the hell
pacman how much is big pharma and george
soros giving you to give us propaganda
nothing
i bet you're y-o-u-r a millionaire from
them not from the common american you're
while you are a sellout and people are
beginning to see this
i couldn't possibly address that
in the way in which it should
substantively be addressed so let me do
a presented without comment thank you
very much to everybody who wrote in info
davidpakman.com bonus show coming up
just me on today's bonus show no pat
pat's gone but you'll get me
for better or worse sign up at
joinpakman.com
otherwise we'll see you after the july
4th holiday